شكرا فدا مرحبا مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
التحليليه للمجريات العسكريه في الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه نرحب باللواء فايز
دويري مرحبا بك وارحب بزميلي عبد القادر
حيث نبدا من القصف الذي يطال مناطق عده
لكن البدايه من الشمال جبالي عبد القادر
نعم محمد ولعل هذا الامر بارز في عمليه
الاستهداف في الشمال ولكن ذلك لا يعني بان
مناطق اخرى كالمناطق الوسطى والجنوب لم
تسلم من هذا القصف وبالحديث عن عمليه
القصف الاسرائيلي يمكن الحديث دوما عن هذه
المناطق الثلاث حينما نقسم قطاع غزه الى
ثلاثه مناطق فعملي القصف استهدفت بالاساس
هذه المناطق الشماليه وتحديدا جباليه لكن
مناطق الوسطى ايضا كان لها نصيب من القصف
الاسرائيلي سواء بدبابات او ايضا بالطيران
وبالاساس مخيم البريج لكن ايضا خان يون
استشهد جمله من التطورات سنتناولها لاحقا
في تفاصيل المشهد لو ذهبنا الى شمال قطاع
غزه وتحديدا في المناطق الشماليه يمكن
الاشاره الى القصف الاسرائيلي الذي طال
العديد من المناطق نحن نتحدث بالاساس عن
المناطق الشماليه ولكن ايضا المناطق
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه ولعل مخيم جباليه كان
في صداره مناطق التي تعرضت لهذا القصف
الاسرائيلي خصوصا منذ هذا الصباح اخر
الاخبار ايضا مع قلته سرايا القدس عن
تمكنها وكتائب القسام من استهداف خمس
اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه او خمس دبابات في
محور جباليا اذا جباليا هي منطقه اجتباك
لازالت مستمره ولكن منطقه استهداف ايضا
اسرائيلي ما يوحي ويدل على ان المنطقه
الشماليه لازالت تعيش على وقع اداء
للمقاومه من خلال استهداف هذه الاليات
ولكن ايضا استهداف اسرائيلي بعمليه قصف
مكثف لهذه المواقع ربما نشير ايضا الى
ايضا تطورات هنا في الشيخ رضوان تحدثت
ايضا سرايا القدس وكتائب القسام عن
استهداف اليتين
عسكريتين على مستوى هذا المحور ربما هناك
تساؤلات تتعلق بحجم التواجد تواجد
الدبابات والاليات العسكريه على مستوى هذا
المحور كنا طرحناه في الايام السابقه وهنا
تعيد ما قالته القناه الثان ع الاسرائيليه
على ان هناك توجها داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي
لتغير استراتيجي في الحرب على غزه والذهاب
الى ما سمته حرب استنزاف ضد حماس وهذا
ربما يحتاج الى تحليل لو ذهبنا الى
المناطق الاخرى وتحديدا في المنطقه جنوبيه
منطقه غزه وتحديدا المنطقه منطقه وسط
القطاع عمليات القصف التي طالت بالاساس
كما قلنا في السابق مخيم البريج والنصيرات
ذلك مع هذا القصف المكثف خصوصا لمخيم
البريج تحدثت كتائب القسام عن عمليه
استهداف هذه المره تحدثت كنا دوما نتحدث
عن استهداف واستدراج لفتحات انفاق تحدثت
عن استهداف فتحه نفق في شرق البريج
وتمكنت من قتل وجرح ثمانيه جنود
اسرائيليين في هذا في هذا الموقع اذا
عمليه ايضا في البريج تحدثت ايضا عن
استهداف اليه او ناقله جوند اسرائيليه هنا
في البريج تحدثت ايضا عن استهدا دبابت
مركزه اذا مخيم البريج في المنطقه الوسطى
الذي يتعرض الى عمليه قصف مكثفه على غرار
ايضا مخيم النصيرات وايضا المغازي يشهد
تطورات لافته في المنطقه الوسطى ولكن
بالمقابل عمليه قصف مكثفه اسرائيليه لو
ذهبنا جنوبا ولعل الاشاره ضروريه الى هذه
التطورات في خان يونس ربما نشير الى ان
التطورات كنا دوما نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه
الشرقيه لكن هناك عمليات قصف ايضا لهذه
المناطق كما اشار لها مراسلنا خصوصا في
المناطق القريبه من بني سهيله ولكن ايضا
في خزاعه وسط تساؤلات وحديث عن تحركات
للدبابات الاسرائيليه حيث اشارت الصور
للاقمار الصناعيه حصلت عليها الجزيره على
ان هناك تموقع لنحو 300 دبابه في مختلف
مناطق خانيونس وسط تساؤلات عن هذا المشهد
الى اين يتجه خصوصا في ظل وجود مقاومه في
هذه المواقع المقاومه الفلسطينيه لازالت
ايضا تقول كلمتها في هذه المواقع ولكن
هناك تحركات ما على هذا المحور من قبل
القوات الاسرائيليه ربما تطورات لافته على
اكثر من صعيد محمد تضاف لها ايضا عمليه
استهداف غلاف غزه بصواريخ كما حدث في
عسقلان وسدي روت وغيرها شكرا عبد القادر
هذه الخريطه سناتي ايضا على تفسير ما يجري
فيها من من تحركات مع لواء فايز دويري لكن
قبل ذلك لواء فايز لنتابع اذا مجموعه من
الفيديوهات التي بثتها المقاومه ونبدا
بالكمين الذي نصب لقوه راجله القسام كان
عرض فيديو لاستهداف قوه راجله لنتابع اذا
هذا الفيديو ونعود
بالتحليل ايضا ما منا من فيديوهات
نتابع
[موسيقى]
ا
اذا لواء فايز انت تابعت هذا المنزل الذي
تم تفخيخ ومن ثم تفجيره قد اعلن القسام في
هذا الفيديو تفاصيل ما ما جرى ما قراءتك
التحليليه لما استخدمه ايضا هي اولا عمليه
تدل على عمليه دقه في ال المعلومات
والقراءه الاستشراف يبدو هذا البيت له
موقع موقعه مميز وبالتالي كان هناك توقع
ان قوات الجيش الاحتلال قد تدخل الى هذا
البيت فتم تحضيره مسبقا
بالحشوات
التدميريه وتم وضع اكثر من حشوه لم تكن
التفصيلات اظهار الحشوات وتوضيحها واضحا
بصوره كامله لكن ها هو يعمل على تحذيرها
خلف الكنبايه في مناطق مختلفه وبالتالي
عمليه توصيلها الان هو يسحب الاسلاك
ال المستخدمه يبدو انه تفجير كهربائي اي
من لانه طبيعه الاسلاك من خلال المشاهده
رغم عدم وضوح الصوره لانه هذا يتم تجهيزه
اما بالكورت او ما يطلق عليه الكورتكس
فتيل التفجير السريع او من خلال الكهربائ
الان دخلت هذه المجموعه يعني التخطيط كان
دقيق والتوقع كان في مكانه الان يدخل يتم
يتم التفجير هم هم تحدثوا عن استخدام
عبوات تصادميه وافراد وشوا هذ هذه ال يعني
ثلاث انواع الان هذه تتعلق ال الصادمه
الحشوه الصادمه تتعلق بتقنيه تحضير وتضيع
الحشوات حشوه الشواظ لها استخدام اخر لانه
اكبر حجما وجاهزه الحشوات الاخرى يمكن ان
تح تجهز في نفس المكان فقط توفر المتفجرات
العجين وتحضيرها و وضع الكبسوله فيها
وتوصيلها اما بالكورت او بالسلك الكهربائي
هذه حشوه الشواط هذه جاهزه مده سلفا ويوجد
في مقر لوضع الكبسوله ها هو لاحظ السلك
هذا الان يكون هناك عمليه توصيله سواء
الان بكبسوله كهربائيه او بكبسوله عاديه
حسب التقنيه التي او الامكانات المتاحه
للمستخدم لانه انا اي طريقه من الطريقتين
من موجوده استطيع ان انفذ العمليه بدقه
وعنايه وبالتالي هذه متفجرات عجين شديده
الانفجار بتعادل
1.34 من قوه التي ان تي لاحظ الان عندما
تنفجر بالامس لاحظنا هذا هذا يعني عمليه
تصوير لكن بالامس لاحظنا حقيقه عندما وضعت
خلف الدبابه وتم تفجيرها ولاحظنا قوه
الانفجار هذا يعود لاستخدام النحاس هي هذه
الحشوه هو عندما عرض عرض الجزء المسطح
منها هذه توضع وتوجه الان الداخلي في
البعد الداخلي تسمى الحشوه الفي او شكل
الفي في الاحرف الانجليزيه وبالتالي تكون
مغلفه بالنحاس عندما يحدث الانفجار
بالتالي النحاس يتكور وينطلق
ككتله كتله من من النحاس الحراره العاليه
بسرعه عاليه تخترق الجسم وتؤدي الى تفجيره
وبالتالي هذا سميت اي للمفرده في القران
الكريم
شواظ نعود الان لما نشرته كتابه القسام
حيث اعلن التفجير فتحه نفق في قوه
اسرائيليه مكونه من ثمانيه جنود شرق مخيم
البريج وايقاع بين قتيل وجريح في شرق مخيم
البريج ايضا اكدت القسام استهداف دبابتين
ميركافا بقذيفه الياسين 105 واستهداف
ناقله جند شمال شرق البريج وايقاع عناصرها
بين قتيل وجريح وبثت القسام صورا اذا
للاستهداف استهداف قوه راجله اسرائيليه
متوغلا ولكن في منطقه الشيخ زايد شمالي
قطع غزه
[موسيقى]
نتابع
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر اذا اللواء فائز التصوير لاستدراج
قوه راجله دخول البيت ثم تفجير حااولت
يعني اقوم بعمليه العد كانوا سبعه سبعه
جنود سبعه جنود دخلوا نعم دخلوا هذا
المبنى دخلوا هذا المبنى وكانت النهايه
الحتميه في
حال تم استهدافه و وبالتالي كما نقول
دائما وابدا يعني هذه المنطقه اذا تحدثنا
عن منطقه ابراج الشيخ زاد تتحدث عن نهايه
المنطقه الزراعيه والتقاه مع مع طريق مع
طريق ج مع شارع جباليا وبالتالي هذه يفترض
انها حسب المفاهيم الجيش الاحتلال انها
امنه كما كان يتحدث بان بيت حانون وجحر
الديك مناطق امنه لكن هذه هذه النتيجه هي
يعني هذا لاحظ في اخر فيديو هين كانت
عمليه
يعني فيها بعد نظر في في الناحيه
التخطيطيه والتحضير سواء تفجير تحضير
المنزل قبل دخول القوه من ثم تفجيره
واستدراجهم الى هذه النقطه يعني فيها
اي استناد الى معلومات بغض النظر عن
الوسيله الت يحصل عليها لكن معلومات
موثوقه بحيث مكنتهم من تنفيذ المهمه بنجاح
ونجاح واذا عدنا الى الوضع الراهن
والخريطه تمركز الاليات وعبد القادر بدا
بشرح الخريطه سنشاهدها من الشمال
المعلومات ووصول الناس الى منطقه بيت حنون
او حتى بيت لاهيه تراجع الاليات من
المنطقه التي شاهدناها قبل قليل ابراج
الشيخ زايد ايضا الانسحاب من مناطق في
جباليه باتجاه الشيخ رضوان ما الذي تقراه
في اعاده تموضع الاليات الان هو يعني
استبق هذه التحركات بالحديث عن المنطقه عن
المرحله الثالثه نعم وهي مرحله اعاده
تموضع وليس اعاده انتشار اعاده تموضع لانه
تحدث عن المرحله الثالثه وتحدث عن المنطقه
العازله والمنطقه العازله في المفهوم ال
الجيش الاحتلال والكيان الاسرائيلي
السيطره على المناطق الزراعيه وهي تشكل
تقريبا اذا اعتبرنا وادي غزه من ضم ضمنها
ما يقارب 50% من المساحه الاجماليه
وبالتالي بدا بسحب القوات بقيت له قوات
محدوده في الشيخ رضوان وفي اطراف مخيم
جباليه وجباليا لكن لحتى اللحظه لا يوجد
اي صور جويه نستطيع من خلالها ان نحدد اي
كيفيه واين وكيفيه كيف واين لعمليات
التموضع لانه تقصد داخل القطاع ام خارج
القطاع نعم هو التموضع مبدئيا سيكون داخل
القطاع نعم مبدئيا لانه اذا تموضع خارج لا
تصبح المعادله مختلفه لكن هو سيجبر على
هذا الت حركه لكن مبدئيا سيكون التموضع
داخل قطاع غزه لكن انا قصدت نقطه
اخرى لو تمكن لو كان في مجال الحصول على
صور اقمار صناعيه نحدد من خلاها اماكن
تموضع نستطيع
قراءه ما هي الوظيفه المستقبليه لهذه
القوات لانه قد يكون اقول هنا قد يكون
محاوله اختبار الواجهه الشرقيه في منطقه
التفاح والشجاع مره اخرى بناء على مجريات
المعركه الحاليه والانسحابات التي جرت من
جباليا ومخيم جباليا لانه منطقه التفاح لم
تختبر حتى هذه اللحظه بصوره فاعله كما جرى
في الشجاعيه شود الاعيان يتحدثوا التفاح
والدرج ما زالت الاليات موجوده اوكي لكن
لم يتم اختبارها بقتال حقيقي كما جرى في
الشجاعيه
وبالتالي انا اطرح تساؤل كقراء هل هل يفكر
في ذلك قد يكون لكن لماذا انا قلت لو كان
توفر لدينا س اقمار صناعيه قد تكون
قراءتنا موضوعيه اكثر من ذلك اذا ذهبنا
الى المنطقه الوسطى جحر الديك لا يزال
معروف الان منطقه نصيرات البريج لاحظ شارع
صلاح الدين من اين يمر شارع صلاح الدين
يقسم المنطقتين وهو يتعمد دائما استخدام
الطرق في بعض الحالات لانه تساعده على
سرعه الحركه لانه في حاله سرعه الحركه
يتوقع ان رد الفعل يكون ابطا من سرعه
الحركه وهذه ماخوذه من نظريات الحرب
العالميه الثانيه المرشال رومل وبالتالي
قد يحاول الاندفاع ليجبر الفصل وخاصه انه
القراءه ال لطبيعه المنطقه
وا اليه اداره الدفاع للمقاومه في في
الكتائب على اطار جغرافي فبالتالي هو
يفترض بان هذه المنطقه ستكون المنطقه
التماس ما بين القوات المدافعه عن البريج
والقوات المدافعه عن ميرات وبالتالي
في العلم العسكري مناطق التماس تعتبر
مناطق ضعيفه اذا سيحاول وهو حااول في في
القاطع الشمالي عندما دخل تقريبا من نقاط
التماس في معظم في معظم تدخلاته كانت من
مناطق التماس ما بين حدود المسؤوليه
للقوات المدافعه فاعتقد س سيحاول ان يجرب
وبهذا الصباح كان في هناك عده محاولات لكن
تم التصدي لها وايقاع خسائر كبير فيها
للتوضيح دكتور هي معظم التغت في شرق
البريج اما عن القصف فهو يتركز على البريش
ايضا المناطق الشماليه من الصير يعني
تابعت في بعض المواقع وجدت انه هناك
اشارات الى تحرك قوات في المنطقه التي تقع
بين البريج وبين الصيرات وكان هناك عمليات
استهداف لها وتوقفت وتراجعت وبالتالي بناء
على هذه المعلومات انا اقول لك لانه يبحث
دائما للدخول من المناطق التي تعتبر عيفه
دفاعيا اذا اتجهنا
جنوبا سريعا لاننا سناخذ نقطه الاباتشي
سريعا في في خانيونس ما الذي تقراه كان
عبد القادر يشير الى اليات عدد كبير 300
300 اليه مدرعه وهذا ما يعادل لوائين
مدرعين اعتقد الان بسبب التعثر في منطقه
بن سيلا بصوره عامه عبسان الجديده الكبيره
خزاعه
الزنه الفخاري منها للجنوب هناك تعثر في
المعركه وهي معركه كسر عظم اذا ما هو
البديل لديه اتوقع سيقوم بدفع هذه القوات
لتواصل حركتها باتجاه ابراج او مدينه
الحمد ليعمل احاطه الى منطقه المواصي
والى المستوطنه جوش قطيف حتى ي يقوم
بمحاوله تطويق مدينه غزه هذه بعج مدينه
خانيونس نعم عفوا مدينه خانيونس الان
بعيدا عن الخريطه هنالك طلب اسرائيلي
بتزويد الولايات المتحده له
بمروحيات الاباتشي ما الذي تمتلكه اسرائيل
ولماذا الطلب بالمزيد حسب المعلومات يوجد
في اسرائيل اسرائيل 48 طائره اباتشي الان
هذا الطلب غير معروف العدد الموافقه
المبدئيه لم تحصل هذه الطائره تعتبر طائره
متميزه في عمليات القتال خاصه في المناطق
المبنيه وضد الاليات المدرعه وضد الاهداف
القاسيه والطريه تحمل رشاش 30 ملم اي ب
سرعته 320 طلقه في الدقيقه مداه 4 كيلو
وتحمل 16 صاروخ هيلفاير مداه 11 كيلو لكن
هناك نقطه كان هناك اعلان انه تم دعوه
الطيارين المتقاعدين الذين كانوا يستخدموا
ه يطيروا على هذه الطائرات
ورفعوا الطلب كان يغطي عمر حتى سن 50 عا
55 عاما عليهم العوده والالتحاق يبدو لانه
الطيار يقضي في بعض الحالات اربع ساعات
داخل الطائره وهذا وقت يسبب الارهاق
والتعب فبالتالي طلبوا دعوه ال الاحتياط
والمتقاعدين حتى عمر 55 عام طيب الان ما
الذي تتوقعه من الاداره الامريكيه هل
ستستجيب حتى اللحظه لا يوجد استجابه
استنادا الى التصريحات السابقه تم الفصل
وعندما تحدث الرئيس بايدن وتحدث ب واعتبرت
انعطاف في بال المقاربه السياسيه
الامريكيه في ثاني ثاني يوم في اليوم
اللاحق تم التصريح من اكثر من مسؤول حتى
مستوى الجنرال اوستن تحدثوا بان امريكا
ملتزمه بتقديم احتياجات اسرائيل العسكريه
طيب الان كان عبد القادر يشير استنادا لما
نشاهده في الشمال الى الانتقال الى مرحله
اخرى تكون اقل كثافه لكن ما يجري في
الجنوب سواء في الوسط او في الجنوب هو
خلاف ذلك ما تفسيرك لا هو الان يعني يجب
ان نفصل بين المنطقه الشماليه والمنطقه
الجنوبيه في القاطع الشمالي هو جرب حظه
كما يقال وكانت النتائج وخيمه من حيث عدد
الاليات وال والقتلى والجرحى ولم يستطع ان
يحقق اي هدف عسكري وبالتالي اجبر على
التراجع والانسحاب والانكفاء اذا هو يحال
ان يجرب حظه اعتقد هذ المعركه قد يكون لها
اطار زمني اسبوعين اسبوعين ونص هكذا اقرا
ولكن ب في بنهايه اسبوعين اسبوعين ونص
ماكسيمم ثلاثه اسابيع اعتقد سيكون مصيره
كمصير في القاطع الشمالي في في دقيقه هذه
مواصفات الاباتشي هل لها علاقه زياده عدد
طائرات الاباتشي بالمرحله الجديده نعم نعم
هو الان لكن السؤال متى يعني متى ستوافق
الاداره الامريكيه علما انه تم هناك
قوانين طوارئ انه يستطيع اي ارسال الاسلحه
والمعدات دون الرجوع لاخذ موافقه الكونجرس
وهذا ما يمكن اعتماده وبالتالي اذا اتخذ
القرار يتم الشحن في طائرات الهركليز
العملاقه ويتم ارسالها وتستطيع الوصول
خلال ايام اذا المعركه في في المنطقه
الجنوبيه قد تاخذ اسبوعين الى ثلاث اسابيع
اعتقد لكن الجيش الاسرائيلي لن يقوى على
انجاز ما لم ما عجز عن انجازه في المنطقه
هل هذه فتره كافيه لتزويد اسرائيل بمزيد
من المروحيات يمكن يعني الان اذا كانت هذه
اذا ارادوا ان يعطوهم من مخزونات الجيش
الامريكي مباشره فاعتقد انه عمليه يحمل
ويشحن بس هذا يعتمد على اليه اتخاذ القرار
الانيه في ظل استخدام القانون القانون
الخاص بالتزويد دون الرجوع للكونجرس
اللواء فائز دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك